okay so here we are another episode of
eating your feed
today we're going to make a flaming
wheel of cheesy pasta
that adam has challenged me to recreate
there's a place called petit paris you
have this wheel of cheese that has the
top taken off of it some liquor is
lit on fire they make a cream sauce they
dump the pasta in
swirl it around then it's done you need
to get a wheel of cheese i think
you can get it on william sonoma for
hundred dollars costco nine hundred
dollars
okay we're gonna buy a 72
pound nine hundred dollar wheel of
cheese
the costco product description says
features
aged 24 months imported from italy
extravagant
okay all right we're gonna use the cart
[Music]
okay so here's the package 80 pound
warning on it
so this is rea tasty producer
extraordinaire
eating your feed designated savior
i can melt this bit
today i think i'm gonna need a lot of
help okay let's open it
it's like christmas
whoa is this a crap brand
zanetti says typical parmesan
typical parmesan no this is good this is
good stuff
oh we got a big wheeled cheese
the next thing i have to do is chop this
lid off any concerns
just don't hurt yourself it's very
difficult to cut
i'd worry about it slipping and chopping
my finger
off yeah that's my biggest concept for
this
okay day three of the cheese adventure
there are some very specific tools that
are typically used
for cutting one of these open instead we
got a bunch of other
tools this is more of like a sandwich
spread knife oyster shucker
butter knife hammer to kind of try you
know and we got
cut safe gloves
where do you start i'm gonna go to this
little serrated blade
and just try to score is it gonna take
hours just this alone
struck cheese mmm that smells good
let's just try doing the oyster and then
just kind of
oh god like leonardo da vinci
[Music]
cheese break oh this cheese is so good
oh the smell is like a smell explosion
we're just gonna
have to pop the rim off this bad boy
all right so we got that now look i'm
cheesus
also kind of like a toilet seat that's
okay though yeah now it's a matter of
just uh
cleaning it up look at this it's so pure
[Music]
we have taken out all the top layer
and start forming the bowl
adam stop eating cheese like we're good
to go we're ready to start making cheese
here
i want to do a test run before i have
any pasta how much
cognac do you think i should use let's
do a quarter cup
just a quarter no half a cup
half a cup that seems like a good amount
why is cognac good for flambe
it has a higher alcohol percentage kind
of has a like
mild sleep flavor so i have my blow
torch
have you done flambe before no never
[Music]
that on fire no
oh it's on fire is it yay
it's gone you want to
kind of wet around it so
soaking a wheel of cheese with fire
right now adam okay so there it's kind
of on fire
i want to scoop it out i'm nervous that
we're ruining the cheese
you see the flame this is a whole lot
me too do you wanna do you wanna
extinguish it
yeah i'm just gonna put this on top to
extinguish it okay
it smells like a cheesy alcoholic
concoction uh we can use it for later
tastes so bad
all right so i'm going to scrape up a
little bit of this cheese
attempt to raise a little bite at all
okay
[Music]
now i'm just going to oh yeah spread the
cheese around
oh man it's just like salty alcohol
more cheese and less brandy i want to
carve out the bowl
so that it's shallower and that way the
alcohol
can all be on fire at once okay one
tablespoon
is it too little two tablespoons yeah
so i'm weighing out my pasta because i
want to do the same amount every time
so this time i'm gonna scrape up a
little bit more
cheese ignited pour it in now
is it extinguished
looks like it is i mean the pasta is hot
yeah okay i'm gonna keep going with my
pasta here
okay that looks kind of gnarly at the
moment
i think i had too much cheese all right
i'm gonna take it out
[Music]
it's just alcoholic pasta should i pan
fry it
and see what's gonna happen like once we
completely cook off the alcohol oh it
looks so much better
look at that creamy glisten
basically perfect we did it so
i think you can get to this right maybe
you want to flambe
longer time before you're adding in a
palm
okay this is what's going to happen cook
the pasta then we
toss it in a pan with butter is that too
much butter
no that's not such a thing
that's what i like to hear and a little
bit of starchy water
get that to like a good state you know
in like westerns
how there's always a bartender who's
wiping down a mug
behind the bar i'll start heating the
cognac
two tablespoons get it hot before it's
ignited
okay there it's on fire i'm gonna pour
it out
yeah no you see that
you can see the singed parts
all right pasta goes in there mix it
around a couple times
put it in my eating bowl pepper
it's good yeah it's actually really
tasty
oh it's still a little boozy though
[Music]
time for the best version yet i made the
bowl
a little shallower hopefully that will
help keep the flambe alive
this time i think we're gonna go with
three tablespoons of cognac
[Music]
i'm gonna pour it over my spoon oh
yeah look at that is it more alive this
time
so i think keeping the cognac moving
around
is important to making sure all the
alcohol burns off because when it pulls
some of the alcohol's trap kay yeah that
smells good
i think the cheese actually had more
opportunity to flambe
oh yeah look at that
[Music]
this needs a little salt actually how
did i pick that up
okay we're at the final attempt now
that's why i'm wearing a hat
we're gonna make a cream sauce this time
it's also how they do it in the video
that we're referencing so here's some
minced shallot
grated garlic add some cream into it oh
yeah
this will come together so that it's a
little bit more flavorful
and for the cheese to have a little bit
more to grab onto in the video he
actually
adds a little bit of parmesan to his
sauce so we're going to do that as well
i'm going to do some light scraping of
the wheel here
to get some more cheese crumbs i think i
my chunks were too big
four tablespoons for this portion and
then once people get up here and we're
ready to do the flan bang we're gonna
turn the lights down a little bit so
that you can see the flames a little
better
that's too much okay the lights are down
sauce is nice
people are coming
[Music]
okay stand back everybody
oh yeah
[Music]
yeah cheesy pasta
what do you guys think it looks crazy in
a dark
okay so now it's going in there and yes
it's coming all together sounds like
mouth sounds
everybody's silent
okay i got the thumbs up so here comes
shiny
okay there's a cheesy pasta made in a
flaming
wheel of cheese is it really good
all right i gotta find out the first
time that you
dump a bunch of liquor into a 900 wheel
of cheese
it just kind of sits there uh it's
pretty dark moment
it's a long way back up from there you
can definitely achieve the same thing
without
actually doing it in a wheel of cheese
but come on wheel of cheese that's on
fire
little spoon action pasta goes in there
pretty fun and uh i think it tastes
pretty good we
figured out how to make this thing now i
have a lot of
cheese to share with everybody should we
save the bowl so that we can make more
you want to see more right yeah all
right let's do it
oh yes
you